if I give away a 10 massage to get
people to come in and then later
everyone buys packages of massages from
me or buys a massage subscription from
me the massage subscription or the
massage packages are my core offer and
the lead magnet would be the trial offer
of the 10 or discounted massage the
reason people do those discounted
massages is because they make more money
because if I go up to 100 people and say
hey let me give you a massage for 100
bucks a lot of people might say no maybe
one person would say us now if I then
said I want to give you a massage for
ten dollars I might get 20 people to say
yes and then of those 20 get a third of
them to buy the hundred thing after they
tried my massage and so you've got one
person getting a massage for 100 versus
six people getting a massage after
giving them that first trial so if it
cost me ten dollars in cost to give the
massage then I break even on my lead
magnet if it actually cost me 20 I might
lose 10 bucks but am I willing to lose
10 bucks on 20 people so I pay 200 to
get six customers that convert and are
worth two thousand